58 actos de terrorismo se suman tan solo
la ciudad de guayaquil ciudad costera de
ecuador en donde la criminalidad avanza
sin control la cultura del miedo y el
silencio ya forma parte de los barrios
de la ciudad portuaria en las grandes
recompensas motivan a los habitantes del
barrio cristo del consuelo a colaborar
con las autoridades para esclarecer la
explosión de una bomba la madrugada de
este domingo que contabilizan cinco
fallecidos y 20 heridos la explosión fue
tan fuerte que se sintió a 70 metros de
distancia el estado nacional calificó la
mente como un hecho terrorista sin
precedentes en el país santino el
presidente de la república decretó su
tercer estado de sección para controlar
la criminalidad en el país los dos
anteriores se declararon en octubre 2021
y el pasado mes de abril 2022 el más
reciente fue dirigido contra un líder de
una banda delictiva a causa del control
de territorios las muertes violentas
siguen avanzando en la ciudad de
guayaquil y asuman 512 muertes violentas
entre los meses de enero y junio según
datos de la publicidad nacional es que
la inseguridad ha pasado a ser la mayor
preocupación de los ecuatorianos